dieses Thema Bevormundung also hätte man
das
kommen sehen müssen
dass man da ja letzten Endes in den
Heizungskeller von von 85 Millionen
reinsteigt ja ist ja nicht ist ja nicht
trivial mit Jürgen Trittin mal hier
darüber gesprochen der sagte ich hatte
es einfach im Vergleich zu Robert Habeck
weil ich musste mich mit ein paar
Gewerkschaften ein paar großen
Energiekonzernen rumschlagen die hatte
ich einigermaßen im Griff er legt sich
mit 80 Millionen an frag mich trotzdem
wie konnte das passieren dass man das
nicht hat kommen sehen dieses die das
zum Beispiel dieses Gefühl entsteht der
Bevormundung
das erste ist der Gebäudesektor der
Verkehrssektor hängen nach bei der
Erfüllung der Klimaziele also musste man
anders als bei der Industrie der ein
besonderen Schwerpunkt setzen wo ist der
Wärme wo ist der Gebäudebereich am
intensivsten betroffen bei Dämmung und
Beheizung und beides geht ans
Portemonnaie und deswegen war klar
welche Lösung immer gewählt wird dass
sie unpopulär sein wird und umso und
Robert habe wirklich eine Mangel nicht
an der Mangel an kommunikationskunst das
dann so
introvertiert so bezogen auf eine Lösung
dann kam noch hinzu der Skandal um den
Staatssekretär wo das dann vom Thema
ablenkte das dann so zu betreiben
meine ehemalige Chefin Angela Merkel die
hat bei sowas immer gesagt wenn das
irgendwie schief eingetütet war sie
gesagt der rot kein Segen drauf und wenn
es so ist dann kriegen sie es kaum noch
Repariert
und was macht man dann um dieses Gefühl
der Bevormundung wieder wegzukriegen
also ich von vorne anfangen wie erstmal
schon mal gemacht hat bei dem Thema was
war das gaspreisbremse hat es ja schon
mal gemacht die Umlage genau seit dem
gar nicht so geschadet beim zweiten Mal
wäre es natürlich noch ärger gewesen
aber wenn es irgendwie aus falsche
glasgesetzt ist dann macht es wenig Sinn
mit der Dampfmaschine dieses Glas weiter
zu beschreiben da muss man umkehren und
neu machen und ich glaube sogar dass
dann auch wenn es jetzt zum zweiten Mal
wäre das ein Fehler eingestanden wird
und noch mal neu angefangen wird es bei
den Leuten den besseren Eindruck
hinterlässt wenn man es schafft das
souverän zu sagen auch zu erklären warum
diese unter Druck stehen warum die auch
unter so hohen Zeitdruck arbeiten und
dann natürlich eben auch mal Sachen
schief gehen ich glaube das kommt besser
an als wenn man versucht auf Biegen und
Brechen was schön zu reden und noch ins
Ziel zu bringen wo in Wahrheit wirklich
jeder intuitiv merkt das ist nicht der
Weisheit letzter Schluss ne das
funktioniert
da jetzt schon auf der Spur auf einer
der fährt sozusagen wenn es angeht den
Aufstieg der AFD zu erklären da kommen
natürlich wahnsinnig viele Faktoren
Stichwort im Hinterkopf ja also es
kommen unheimlich viele Faktoren
zusammen und manchmal
sieht man vielleicht auch die Verbindung
zu schnell zu sagen und das nützt jetzt
der AFD also was man glaube ich
feststellen kann ohne was falsches zu
sagen ist dass es die Politik
Verdrossenheit nennen was mal so
befördert wenn Menschen die ein viel
feineres Gespür dafür haben ob Sachen
funktionieren und gut durchdacht sind
oder nicht als man manchmal glaubt also
ich denke manchmal dass man in den
entscheidungszentren auch oft davon
ausgeht die Leute würden sich gar nicht
so Detail detailliert informieren und so
das mag auch sein aber es gibt so ein
Grundgefühl dafür ob der gute Arbeit
geleistet wird oder nicht und wenn das
nicht der Fall ist merken Menschen das
und wenn dann noch was rauskommt was als
bevor Mundung empfunden wird dann geht
wieder sozusagen das nächste halbe Kilo
Vertrauen verloren und das nützt dann
indirekt möglicherweise auch der AFD
wenn die das schaffen das auf sich
umzumünzen deswegen sagte ich gerade
eine der Fährten sozusagen ich habe
irgendwo gelesen Herr die mir sehr da
haben Sie darüber nachgedacht dass es da
was Heizungskeller angeht einen
signifikanten Unterschied gibt zwischen
Ost und West worin besteht der könnte
das einmal erklären ich fand das sehr
interessant und plötzlich wurde so
greifbar und zunächst mal sagen dass wir
ein Rechtspopulismus in ganz Europa
haben
nicht nur in Deutschland das hat zu tun
mit mit Ablehnung von modernen von
Globalisierung gesellschaftspolitischen
Entwicklung so dass sagen wir mal 10 bis
15 Prozent manchmal 20 %
in Finnland in
Deutschland in
Niederlande in Spanien Italien und so
weiter und jetzt in Schweden ganz in
unsere Überraschungen und jetzt kommt
das ist extra Thema das schwierig genug
und möglicherweise werden wir damit das
lange noch beschäftigen jetzt kommen
aber noch zehn Prozent oder 15% je
nachdem im Osten dazu und da ist
Grundlage woran liegt das auch das hat
viele Ursachen Frau C hat das eben eine
angedeutet was das heizungsthema angeht
muss man natürlich wissen dass die
gesamte Wohn- und heizsituation sich
nach 1990 im Osten komplett verändert
hat sowohl in den Wohnungen aber auch in
sehr vielen Einfamilienhäusern ganz
viele Ostdeutsche haben
Einfamilienhäuser selbst gebaut bekommen
umgebaut jetzt sind die ersten Häuschen
abbezahlt die Finanzierung ist halbwegs
gesichert die Generation die das gemacht
hat ist in Rente gegangen da gibt es
keine großen Rücklagen durch Erbschaften
oder oder betriebliche Zusatzversorgung
und jetzt in einer Heizung die vor 10 15
Jahren eingebaut ist die nochmal 10 15
Jahre hält jetzt zu sagen dass es ihr
aufgebaut habt müsst ihr rausreißen
das ist ganz anders als im Westen im
Westen ist kontinuierlich durch Bau und
Umbau ist immer meine neue Heizung Fälle
im Osten hat eine ganze Generation ein
neues Haus ein neuer Heizung eine neue
Anlage gekauft und die wird in Frage
gestellt und das in einer und jetzt bin
ich noch mal weiter bevor man in einer
Art wenn ihr das nicht wollt dann seid
ihr irgendwie gegen Klimaschutz und
diese Kausalität wird abgelehnt und die
mangelnde Verständnis dafür wird das
Bevormundung wahrgenommen jetzt muss man
einmal kurz sagen ne so stand es ja in
dem Gesetz nie drin ich weiß aber das
hat er nie einer gesagt ihr müsst jetzt
eure Heizungen rausreißen aber das
Gefühl ist entstanden auch in dem alten
Gesetz was meine Regierung noch gemacht
hat war auch von Umrüstung die Rede in
einem etwas längeren Zeitplan das ist so
aber der andere ist entstanden und der
andere ist auch wichtiger als die Sache
in der Politik
das heißt Edmund Stoiber der glaube ich
mal gesagt hat in der Politik sind
Emotionen Fakten
hat an dem Punkt aber natürlich nicht
nur Fakten sagen aber klar bezogen auf
genau aber das ist jedenfalls was wie
sieht es denn français aber der der
Unterschied in der Wohnsituation nach
1990 alles neu nicht sofort mit dem
ersten Wohlstand wurde dann wurden die
Häuschen gebaut also das ist ein großer
Unterschied zum besten oder aus meiner
Erfahrung kommen noch was anderes hinzu
dieses Thema Heizen ist in den Gegenden
wo ich unterwegs bin auch oft noch so
eine so ein Autonomie Erfahrung also man
ist noch nicht ganz so wie es vielleicht
eher am besten der Fall ist daran
gewöhnt oder empfindet das auch als
komfortabel alles irgendwie geliefert
hingestellt
vorgetunt zu bekommen sondern es gibt
unheimlich viele Leute die heizen zum
Teil auch noch zu mit selbst
geschlagenem Holz sie haben irgendwie
noch einen Dauerbrenner stehen machen so
mischgeschichten und haben immer das
Gefühl zur Not könnten wir selbst
Versorger sein und da geht es zum einen
natürlich auch darum einfach die Kosten
möglichst gering zu halten weil das
Einkommensniveau ist zum Teil einfach
sehr niedrig es ist aber glaube ich auch
so ein identitäts Ding also es gibt so
ein Gefühl von
wir fliegen auch unterm Radar ja das hat
eine lange Geschichte wir könnten zur
Not irgendwie alleine klarkommen wir
brauchen diesen Staat vielleicht auch
nicht so dringend wir machen hier so ein
bisschen unser eigenes Ding und ich
glaube so ein gefühlter Anschlusszwang
da ja das triggert auch noch mal so ein
so ein ablehnungsreflex also man möchte
irgendwie auch unabhängig bleiben seine
eigene Versorgungslage entscheiden
können weil man eher darauf vertraut
dass man es irgendwie hinkriegt
vielleicht auch so in der Gemeinschaft
mit den anderen und nicht so sehr darauf
vertraut dass der Staat das immer alles
vorsorgt und berechnet und dann passt
das schon
gut dabei Beispiel gutes Beispiel wir
hatten schon mal eine solche Prozesse
sie sagen Anschlusszwang bei den Fragen
Abfallentsorgung Sickergruben haben
viele ostdeutscher ich habe eine
Sickergrube ich entsorge die warum ich
in weit weg vom nächsten Ort warum
verlangt eine europäische Richtlinie von
mir eine anschluss- und Benutzungszwang
mit einer zentralen Kläranlage auf meine
Kosten der Staat macht die Regeln und
ich muss es bezahlen das war ein riesen
Protest hat die Verwaltungsgerichte
massiv beschäftigen
wie aus weil es interessiert mich gerade
also zum Teil wurden mussten Leute
entschädigt werden die gezwungen worden
waren sich anzuschließen obwohl es
sozusagen nicht nötig gewesen wäre zum
Teil wurde angeschlossen aber es war
tatsächlich ein Situation die die
Gemüter wahnsinnig erhitzt hat und ich
glaube dass das auch sehr anschaulich
ist also es klingt vielleicht wenn man
die Verhältnisse nicht kennt auf den
ersten Blick so ein bisschen lächerlich
wie man sich darüber aufregen kann aber
man muss wirklich sagen es ist nicht
trivial es geht ums Geld aber es ist
auch so ein Pragmatismus dahinter den
ich zum Teil auch sympathisch finde weil
die Leute sehr oft danach fragen wie
funktioniert das und macht das Sinn und
wenn die sagen das ist doch nicht
umweltschädlicher oder so wenn wir das
hier vor Ort lösen warum muss immer
alles irgendwohin transportiert und
woanders weiterverwertet werden haben
die vielleicht ja auch die richtige
Intuition also es gibt eben auch so eine
Sehnsucht nach in sich logischen
Problemlösungen und oft führt ja auch
Zentralisierung zu einem Gefühl von
Absurdität weil Dinge dann ewig durch
die Gegend gekutscht werden wie in dem
Fall zum Beispiel eben Abwasser ja
das ist auch schlimm auch
es gibt im Osten eine stärkere ich nenne
das mal Ingenieurs Mentalität also im
Westen also dieser problemlösungs gehen
ich habe das gelernt ich habe zu der
Herzen gut improvisieren können sagen
viele und jetzt kommt irgendwie eine
technische Vorschrift aus Berlin die
mich nicht so richtig überzeugt warum
können wir das nicht selber machen
dieses Autonomie denken ist sehr weit
vorbei und
auch noch hinzu kommt jetzt werfen wir
mal alle irgendwie auch positiven
ostdeutschen Eigenschaften auf einem
Haus und das mal zu hören es gibt eine
wiederverwertungsmentalität also man
schmeißt sehr ungern Dinge weg also ich
kenne das so dass man alles aufhebt was
mal kaputt gegangen ist das sieht dann
nicht immer schön aus wenn man das alles
irgendwo im Garten sammelt aber man kann
halt immer wenn was anderes kaputt ist
hat man sein Ersatzteillager und
repariert das und letztlich muss man
sagen dass diese Mentalität jetzt unterm
Gesichtspunkt von Klimaschutz und so
weiter ja auch nicht falsch ist ja also
weil jedes neu erzeugte Produkt was im
Rahmen der Globalisierung weltweit hin
und hergefahren zusammengebaut und noch
mal transportiert wird hat ja am Ende
ein schlechteren Fußabdruck als der 20
mal reparierte
plakativ zu sagen also es gibt eine
gewisse Freude und auch ein stolz darauf
aus alten Dingen wieder etwas zu machen
es weiter zu verwenden und eigentlich
nichts weg zu werden
total entgegen also wenn das Gefühl hat
hier wird was rausgekommen was
eigentlich funktioniert was noch gut ist
darum geht ich muss gerade an die EU
denken und das ride to repair ist ja so
ein Ding ich meine wie lange denken wir
darüber nach die wirklich großen
tech-konzerne Apple und andere dazu zu
verdonnern zusammen pass auf wenn dieses
Telefon kaputt ist dann schmeißen wir
nicht bitteschön das ganze Ding weg oder
der der Computer was auch immer sondern
ihr sorgt bitte dafür dass das und zwar
gesetzlich verpflichten dass das
repariert werden kann
Wirtschaftssystem basiert auf der
wegwerfen Mentalität
ja sozusagen das kleine gallische ja was
spannend innerhalb einer Welt die
eigentlich sagt bitte kauft die alle
zwei Jahre neues Auto ja das machen wir
die richtig schmackhaft weil das ist
volkswirtschaftlich eine gute Idee eben
sagt ja wieso wieso soll ich das machen
warum soll das sinnvoll sein warum bin
ich nicht wenn ich sage ich fahre mein
altes Auto so lange bis das kaputt ist
ich finde das gerade total interessanten
Punkt weil wenn man sich anschaut
eigentlich ist das doch Kunst des
Regierens eigentlich das klingt doch
total simpel und auch einleuchtend dass
man sagt dass aber es gibt dann recht
die Dinge zu reparieren und die haltet
euch bitte daran wenn man sich dann
anschaut was die alles veranstalten das
ist dann am Ende doch nicht geht und
nicht gehen kann und ganz am Ende kommt
dann raus gut wir können das Reparieren
Klammer auf wir tun im Gesetz jetzt
sozusagen genüge aber Klammer zu lohnt
sich nicht also das neu zu kaufen ist
deutlich billiger als das alte Ding zu
reparieren dann merkt man sozusagen was
das auch für ein kultureller Unterschied
ist mit meinem Sohn darüber gesprochen
er sagte papa macht immer klar wir sind
diese Generation die aufgewachsen ist in
dem Gefühl alles ist immer Bling Bling
und alles funktioniert und wenn das
kaputt ist kommt einfach was neues
selbst wenn es nicht kaputt das kommt
trotzdem was ja
ich glaube aber nicht dass das sozusagen
Mentalitäten oder lebenstechniken sind
die man per Gesetz in irgend teilweise
verordnen kann also womit wir auch
wieder beim Thema bevorwundung werden
auch das funktioniert nicht das sind
höchstens Sachen die man vielleicht
durch eine bestimmte Form von
Wertschätzung eher befördern oder
ausbremsen kann und zumindest ist es
eine Erklärung dafür warum Menschen dann
zum Teil wütend sind sie haben das
vorhin kurz erwähnt wenn man ihre
Lebenseinstellung wie zum Beispiel so
begründet ist dann benutzt um ihnen
letztlich ein Vorwurf daraus zu machen
der noch nicht mal Sinn ergibt unter dem
eigenen unter der eigenen Prämisse das
CO2 eingespart werden soll ja also wenn
man dann jemandem sagt und du bist
sozusagen die Umweltsau weil du dir kein
Auto kaufst dann erzeugt das natürlich
also eine ganz vielschichtige geformt
oder wenn man ihn zum Beispiel sagt es
bin ich interessant im in der
Vorbereitung habe ich einen Satz von
Thomas der mir sehr gelesen der sagt
klar können wir darüber reden dass
sozusagen ein ost-west-thema da ist aber
eigentlich ist es viel mehr das Thema
Stadt gegen lange und dieser Tage wie
zur Bestätigung sozusagen eine Zahl
gelesen die ich so interessant fand also
einerseits dieser dieser diese moralisch
aufgeladene Aufforderung immer ihr
benutzt jetzt bitte öffentliche
Verkehrsmittel das Auto lass sie mal
schön stehen und dann liest du dass
Menschen im Schnitt in Deutschland wenn
sie ÖPNV benutzen dreimal länger
unterwegs sind als wenn Sie sich einfach
in die eigene Karre setzen also Klaus
den Leuten Zeit faktisch heißt du
formulierst einen Anspruch aber du sagst
auf der anderen Seite nicht dafür dass
es funktioniert also dieses ist jetzt
auf die Provinz oder bezieht sich das
auch schon auf die Stadt nee bezieht
sich auf aufs Land unterwegs bist genau
unterwegs wäre das wäre ja schon mal ein
Erfolg also bei uns ist es eher so dass
man halt gar nicht unterwegs ist
kommen
und da auch meine ist es gibt und das
ist ein Ergebnis des
Einigungsprozesses gewesen eine Art
selbst Ermächtigung der westdeutschen
über ostdeutsche Urteile abzugeben ihr
seid noch nicht so weit ihr müsst noch
ein bisschen Demokratie lernen
gut die exklie können und nicht so viel
Englisch das wird schon aber da müssen
wir ein paar Kurse machen eure
Ausbildung mussten wir ja auch
anerkennen und so und dieses
dieses nicht hey was bringt die
eigentlich ein was habt ihr geleistet
dann muss ich mal vorstellen wir reden
jetzt über eine Veränderung der
Arbeitswelt wahrscheinlich durch
künstliche Intelligenz im Osten haben 50
60 Prozent der Menschen leben in einem
anderen Beruf nicht bei einem anderen
Arbeitgeber und da wurde gar nicht groß
nach Anerkennen von Abschlüssen gefragt
auch am Anfang der 90er wurde einfach
gemacht und zu sagen wie habt ihr das
eigentlich hinbekommen da können wir
nämlich was lernen für Zuwanderung für
Transformationen und so das findet nicht
statt das also dieses
das sind viele satt dass das
insbesondere in Berlin gesagt wird ihr
seid noch nicht so weit und das zweite
ist Stadt Land genau es wird gesagt denn
es kann Frau cesicher viel bessere
urteilen als ich die ganzen Konzepte die
ganzen Ideen sind immer
aus der Stadt geboren Deutschland Ticket
wohin man guckt und das ist toll dass
Deutschland Ticket in Berlin ist das
eine gute Sache ich wohne in Dresden ist
auch eine gute Sache aber in meinem
ehemaligen Wahlkreis ein Ehepaar zwei
verschiedene Berufe zwei Kinder und
einer Arbeit in den Dresden einer
woanders dann brauchen die zwei Autos
die ihre Kinder irgendwie abzuholen und
zu ihrem Beruf zu kommen und da hilft
das deutschland-ticket mehr oder weniger
gar nicht weil der Bus gar nicht fährt
dann kann man nicht ohne weiteres den
öpn fahren im Land anders gestalten aber
die sozusagen die denke aus der Stadt
und nur die Hälfte der Bevölkerung oder
ungefähr wurden die ist ein Problem in
Deutschland
also ich glaube sogar dass wenn man sich
die die Statistik anguckt das wird sich
noch weiter verstärken also seit den 215
16er Mann ist es ja passiert dass mehr
Menschen in Städten leben als auf dem
Land das war ja bis dahin in der
Geschichte der Menschheit ja anders aber
ich habe neulich interessante Zahl
gelesen bis ungefähr 2030 werden mehr
Menschen in großen Städten leben in
Großstädten leben als in kleineren
Städten das heißt das wird sich immer
weiter konzentrieren und so aber das
haben wir in Deutschland und so ja ja ja
ja ja darüber reden wir und das ist
natürlich ganz interessant und zu
verstehen so wo diese Bevormundung
stattfindet und warum sich stattfindet
ne wenn die einen so viele sind und die
anderen immer weniger werden jetzt
schwierig wobei das ja immer noch
Trend sind von dem wir auch nicht genau
wissen ob sie wirklich so eintreten man
muss ja immer sagen also letztlich ist
es mehr oder weniger halbe halbe also
quasi sich jetzt vorzustellen es gibt
irgendwie die Städte da sind alle und
auf dem Land sind noch so ein Problem
wir wissen aber nicht ob der so bleiben
wird ich kann mir auch vorstellen dass
der sich umkehrt also das ist nicht vor
das sind einfach nur Hochrechnungen
müssen nicht also das ist nicht das
steht nicht fest wenn wir weitere
Entwicklung in der Berufswelt haben die
den Leuten immer mehr ermöglicht auch zu
Hause zu bleiben sie haben ja auch zum
Homeoffice so ein paar Sachen gesagt das
ist ja zurzeit eine ganz massives
Bedürfnis dann haben Menschen auf einmal
auch die Möglichkeit nicht in der Stadt
zu wohnen ja die Arbeitswelt
flexibilisiert sich vielleicht dreht
sich das irgendwann auch total um und
aber das Entscheidende ist glaube ich
dass wir weg müssen von dem Bild
eigentlich würden die Menschen alle in
Städten wohnen und dann gab es noch
diese paar auf dem Land die da irgendwie
übrig geblieben sind während die
Landflucht eigentlich sozusagen da schon
die die Landstriche entvölkert hat das
ist nicht die Realität also die Hälfte
der Deutschen lebt Provinzial ja aber so
die die die Reise ist klar und da gibt's
auch so ein Gefühl und da an dem Punkt
ich hasse eigentlich dieses Wort dieses
abgehängt sein ich finde das wird der
Lebensversicherung
oder ja also ich finde es auch ganz
falsch weil dass du die Vorstellung ist
eines Zugs irgendwo hinfährt und dann
Teile der Bevölkerung zurücklässt
abhängen wissen genau welche Richtung
das geht das stimmt mich auch in den
Begriff wieso das denn eigentlich
das stimmt ja es tut so als wären da so
ein paar schutzbedürftige den man so von
oben nach unten sagen einmal so
paterchalisch über den Kopf streichelt
und sagt wir wissen was gut für euch ist
weil ihr selber seid
wenn wir heizungsgesetz steht da hinten
die Frage auch der Demografie die in den
letzten Jahren immer mal wieder auch
durch Osteuropa gereist und so oder da
kann man das wirklich sehen was das
macht wie das auch an Land verändert mal
Bulgarien ich weiß noch kurz vor der dem
Zusammenbruch der Sowjetunion war die
kommunistische Parteien Bulgarien den
Leuten immer gesagt wir sind bald 9
Millionen heute sind sie runter auf 6
und bald steht da eine fünf so sieht die
Wirklichkeit aus und das spürt man dann
merkt man wie Städte und Dörfer leise
werden es keiner mehr da das heißt das
macht was was macht das mit dem
Demokratieverständnis dieses dieses
Stadt Land Thema aber das wäre da gerade
sprechen ich erlebt das total anders als
sie das jetzt gerade geschildert haben
aber natürlich
super sind ein volles Land genau und die
Zuwanderung erfolgt eben auch nicht
zuletzt in die Provinz und
man kann natürlich immer nur den Radius
überblicken indem man jetzt zufällig
gerade angesiedelt ist aber bei uns ist
der Trend wirklich eher gewesen dass die
Preise für Bauland und so weiter in den
letzten Jahren massiv in die Höhe
geschossen sind das haben sich auf dem
Land sich in Ostdeutschland von ja einem
sehr sehr sehr niedrigen Niveau dann in
sehr kurzer Zeit wahnsinnig angehoben da
hat man nicht das Gefühl wir sind wir
bald nach der letzte das Licht aus
sondern es ist eigentlich eher so dass
alle Händeringen noch ein Handtuch
suchen wo sie sich ein Häuschen drauf
stellen kann also auch das macht was mit
dem Demokratieverständnis aber ich fand
diese ausgangsbeschreibung zu sagen wir
sind hier so eine aussterbende Gegend
und bald gibt's uns nicht mehr das ist
nicht das was ich wahrnehme es ist
auch nicht aus
Essen ich lebe in Sachsen vor zehn lebt
den Brandenburg ein Unterschied ist der
eigentliche Schatz Sachsen ist nicht
Dresden Leipziger sondern die kleinen
Städte das ist nicht langt sondern 30
40.000
Arbeiter wie sie alle heißen die hoch
attraktiv geworden sind da ziehen die
Leute auch gerne hin Komma wenn man ihn
dann zur Arbeit vielleicht in einem
Fabriken Adressen fahren kann zum
Beispiel
aber da entsteht eine ganz großartige
Lebensqualität die anders ist als
absolvieren darf
im guten Sinne und das ist in Thüringen
so das ist in
Sachsen-Anhalt zum Teil so weniger in
Brandenburg und Mecklenburg-Vorpommern
ich meine wenn das alles so schön ist
sie wissen welche Frage sie gerade genau
aber die Frage muss man sich ja wirklich
Stellen ich wir wollten ja nicht sagen
dass alles schön ist wir wollten glaube
ich eher mal die Zustandsbeschreibung
der Mentalität machen wo wir schon die
Tatsache dass jetzt hier wieder zwei
Leute aus Bonn sitzen die den deutschen
Osten erzählen ja eigentlich auch schon
so ein bisschen für sich spricht ne um
das was interessanten gibt es so ein
paar Parallelen sozusagen ne ja also
zumindest sind wir beide Auswanderer vom
Westen in den Osten hinein wir sind in
derselben Stadt geboren genau
zwischen 50 74 und unsere
Väter warente ich bin dann zum
einjähriges Prozess vorher schon nach
West Berlin dann zum einsatzprozessen
nach Leipzig Brandenburg sehr früh sehr
lange ich lebe jetzt eigentlich länger
immer als im Osten als im Westen in
einer sehr stark sozialisiert worden
aber das ver schlecht eigentlich müsste
hier noch einer hingehören der
hier geboren ist und jagen 74 ist also
im Osten geborene der wobei sozusagen
die haben ja beide Perspektiven
sozusagen und das ist ja schon
interessant dass sie auch als gerade als
Verfassungsrichterin in Brandenburg und
soweit das jetzt nicht nur wir ziehen
irgendwohin weil es da besonders nett
und schön ist sondern schon tief verwurz
identifiziert da wo wir wohnen klar das
meine ich das nochmal wenn das so ist
und es gibt ja unglaublich viele
prosperierende gegen den auch gerade in
Sachsen zum Beispiel muss ich anschaut
was da alles angesiedelt wird jetzt
Magdeburg auch Sachsen-Anhalt in dem
Fall Intel und so weiter das wird ja
vieles nach sich ziehen da passieren
Dinge und da entstehen die Jobs der
Zukunft da wird Zukunft gestaltet woher
dann noch mal diese Unzufriedenheit oder
ist das vielleicht eine falsche these
gibt es diese Unzufriedenheit gar nicht
Zufriedenheit aber ich glaube was man
abräumen muss ist ein zu
modifiziertes Bild von wegen es gibt so
eine Art soziale verehlendung die führt
dann zu Unzufriedenheit und das führt
dann zu AFD
weilertum also das
zeigt sich ja auch nicht wenn man sich
anschaut was für Wählerschichten es sind
die der AFD ihre Stimmen geben kann man
jetzt auch nicht sagen das ist
ausschließlich irgendwie die unterste
Einkommensgruppe genau also von der die
die was zu verlieren haben ne genau also
deswegen kann man quasi nicht immer nur
denken das ist dieser abgehängte Osten
hat ja keine Perspektive alle ziehen weg
und der letzte macht das Licht aus und
deswegen werden die alle auf die also
wenn man sich das so vorstellt ist es
falsch und es ist glaube ich auch
deswegen Problem ist falsch zu sehen
weil sie haben es ja eingangs gesagt ich
werde auch nicht müde das zu betonen wir
reden hier ja nicht nur über ein
deutsches Problem das ist ein Problem
der westlichen Hemisphäre auch nicht nur
europäisch ich finde auch dass man das
was in den USA passiert ist
analysieren kann dass das eigentlich
eine Blaupause ist dass man daran auch
sehr viel ablesen kann was uns direkt
mitbetrifft also jetzt zum Beispiel auch
die Frage was für eine politische
Ansprache gibt es für bestimmte
Bedürfnislagen also wenn sich
Politik sozusagen eher akademisch
begreift eine gewisse Blasenbildung
erzeugt und dann gerade eben auch die
eigentlich linken Parteien wie die
Demokraten eben in den USA und wie es in
Deutschland vielleicht die SPD oder die
Linke wäre eben auch sich zunehmend
zurückzieht in so ein eher
akademischeres Selbstverständnis wo man
sitzt und immer was runterreicht der
immer sagt Sozialdemokratie ist wenn man
denen da unten auch mal was abgibt
anstatt zu sagen das kommt aus dem Volk
heraus ja also wir haben auch Leute mit
geographien die Arbeit der Biografien
sind die sitzen jetzt Abgeordnete wenn
das alles nicht mehr gibt wenn diese
Ansprache sich entkoppelt dass das zum
Beispiel wirklich eine Ursache sein kann
für eine Wähler Abwanderung dann auf die
rechtspopulistische Seite also das sind
so Sachen die kann man einfach von dort
lernen und ich glaube die besitzen
gewisse Gültigkeiten auch für uns und
dann gilt das eben auch nicht mehr nur
für Ostdeutschland da kommen eben ein
paar Gründe zu warum die Prozente
vielleicht noch höher sind als die 15
bis 20 die schlimm genug empfehlen
europäischen Ländern
bequeme Haltung zu sagen das ist ein
ostdeutsches Phänomen haben wir nichts
mehr
Wutbürger 13 Prozent
für die noch etwas sozusagen zugrunde
ostdeutschen sagen und dann aber auch
was kritisches das erste ist was
ostdeutsch anders ist als im Westen ist
eine wie ich das nennen würde
veränderungsmüdigkeit wieder aus
Deutschland hat sich so viel geändert
und relativ erfolgreich wir haben eben
schon über die zum Teil abbezahlten
Häuser und so weiter gesehen aber es ist
losigkeit kein großes Problem mehr eine
große Sorge weil das die Kinder keine
Arbeit haben das ist gelöst Klammer auf
auf dem besten Klammer zu
und jetzt ist das gemacht und jetzt
kommt die neue Entwicklung
Globalisierung Digitalisierung
künstliche Intelligenz Klima und hat
jetzt müsst ihr jetzt müsst ihr euch
noch mal ganz neu verändern da sagen
viele nicht mehr mit uns es gibt eine
veränderungsmüdigkeit die in
veränderungswut umschlägt und jede Art
von Veränderung per se ablehnt das ist
auch der globales Phänomen
größere Rolle wegen der großen
Transformation seit 19 wobei das auch
für ganz Osteuropa Geld diesen diesen
Transformation kritisch sagen was ich
nicht verstehe und was nicht wirklich
traurig und wütend macht ist folgendes
wir haben eine Partei die
bezeichnete der Verfassungsschutz als
rechtsextrem Verdachtsfall in Thüringen
als gesichert rechtsextreme die
sogenannten gemäßigen sind fast alle
rausgeschmissen aus dem Bundesvorstand
der intelle Geist ist rechtsextreme und
westdeutsch und das also
deutsche Landbevölkerung die eher
illiberales was Homosexualität und so
weiter angeht eine Frau toll findet
lesbisch ist in der Schweiz wohnt und
kann sich ans anders verhält als sie
auftritt dass sie sozusagen das
irgendwie gut finden ist mehr wirklich
ein Rätsel und das macht mich richtig
wütend sie wählen ja auch zum Teil egal
ob es jemand gemäßigt ist ist oder nicht
ob bekannt oder unbekannt wählen Sie
einfach diese Leute und deswegen der
Bundespräsident hat das kürzlich gesagt
es gibt auch eine eigene Verantwortung
der Bürgerinnen und Bürger wen sie